you
with all the recent political nonsense
that's been going on people are throwing
the word Orwellian around more than
usual whether or not those concerns are
founded there's been a lot of
speculation regarding just what kind of
horrible future the world is headed
towards will we really live in a
dystopian society like George Orwell
presented in this novel in 1984 in my
opinion probably not but where's the fun
in that with all the talk of Russian
meddling in the recent US presidential
election tension between nuclear powers
is brewing now the world has avoided
nuclear war until now but what is that
word to change how many nuclear bombs
would it take to eradicate humanity the
last time nuclear weapons were used in
war was in 1945 on the Japanese cities
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki at the end of
World War two these bombs dubbed fat man
and little boy would be considered
primitive by today's standards and were
actually two different types of bombs
little boy the explosives that destroyed
Hiroshima was a uranium gun-type bomb
which was detonated by firing one piece
of subcritical material into another
triggering a nuclear reaction Batman was
a plutonium implosion type bomb which
was triggered by essentially using
smaller explosives to squeeze the bombs
plutonium core in terms of explosive
power little boy is estimated to have
been between 12 and 18 kilotons of TNT
and fat man between 18 and 23 kilotons a
kiloton is the measurement of the
explosive power of 1,000 tons of TNT by
comparison a modern nuclear warhead can
have a yield exceeding one Megaton and
modern hydrogen bombs which i've lumped
into the same category for this video
can exceed 3.8 megatons which is 260
times more powerful than the explosives
that destroyed Hiroshima even with their
comparatively low yield little boy and
fat man wiped out between 113 and 220
six thousand people between them with
roughly half of those deaths occurring
on the first day with later deaths being
caused by burns radiation sickness and
other injuries if that kind of
destructive power was packed into just
two primitive nukes what kind of
scenario are we looking at today for
this thought experiment we're going to
consider the standard USB 83 nuclear
bomb our baseline with an explosive
yield of 1.2 megatons
we're also going to give Japan a break
and use my hometown of Dallas Texas for
ground zero to start the end of the
world so without further ado let's blow
up my neighborhood the estimated
fatalities from dropping a 1.2 Megaton
nukes mac dab in the middle of dallas
are estimated to be around 200
d7000 with another 649 thousand injured
the initial fireball would have a radius
of over a kilometer anything within that
radius would be instantly vaporized
moving further away from Ground Zero the
air blast radius would be roughly seven
and a half kilometers within this range
most residential buildings would be
obliterated with considerable fatalities
even further out at the thermal
radiation radius of 13.2 kilometers is
where survival becomes slightly more
possible if you did manage to escape the
worst of the blast you'd still be
covered head to toe and third-degree
burns but don't worry you wouldn't feel
it because these burns would extend
through your layers of skin and destroy
the nerves responsible for registering
pain okay so if we're looking at almost
300,000 dead on impact for one b83 bomb
without taking radiation poisoning and
other injuries into account how many
bombs would it take to wipe out the
entire population of the massive
dallas-fort Worth Metroplex as of 2016
DFW had a population of about 7.1
million people assuming each bomb killed
300,000 people it would take 24 bombs to
eradicate every single person at once of
course for whoever is nuking Dallas that
would be hugely wasteful if the bad guys
wanted to kill every human on the planet
at once it would take over a million
bombs which vastly exceeds the roughly
15,000 available and even then many of
those aren't as powerful as b83
so they'd have to take a different
approach instead of simply aiming for
the most fatalities at Ground Zero the
right tactic would be to take out
infrastructure and agriculture a recent
scientific report suggests that 100
nuclear detonations in a fairly short
period of time would produce five
teragrams or five billion kilograms of
soot that would clog the Earth's
stratosphere and block sunlight
destroying much of the planet's ozone
layer and triggering a drop in global
temperature that could last over 25
years this temperature drop combined
with the roughly 80 percent increase in
UV radiation from the wrecked ozone
layer would destroy many land and
sea-based ecosystems and spark a global
famine to kill two birds with one
nuclear stone if we were to target 100
cultural hubs and industrial areas at
once that would knock out electricity
transportation running water food
production communication and would cause
the long-term global effects we just
looked at to make extra sure that the
lethal effects of nuclear war I fully
realize without going overboard we can
consider the average spread of radiation
from our b83 bombs over the course of a
week a lethal dose of radiation can
creep up to 144 kilometers from
zero giving us an effective lethal range
of about 65,000 869 square kilometres
per bomb so if we take the total amount
of land inhabited by humans roughly
eighteen point six million kilometers
and divide that by our lethal range
you're looking at about two hundred
eighty three bombs if everything went
according to our evil plan and we took
out all the big cultural hubs around the
world that would mean that functional
hospitals would be few and far between
and would often be unable to treat the
victims of severe burns and radiation
poisoning over the course of the two
weeks following the attack millions if
not billions would die from their
injuries and severe radiation poisoning
so hypothetically speaking it could
feasibly take as few as 100 b83 bombs to
knock humanity into critically
endangered status to be thorough and
basically ensure extinction would take
around three hundred could isolated
pockets of humanity survive this nuclear
winter possibly if they managed to avoid
the radiation at some remote Siberian
outpost and had sustainable resources
they could feasibly save the species but
it would take a long long time to
rebuild civilization as we know it and
there's your depressing speculation for
the day go watch a cat video or
something as always this video is
intended to spark your curiosity if
you're interested in learning more about
nuclear weapons and their effect check
out the links in the description if you
enjoyed this video please take a moment
to subscribe to my channel your support
makes a big difference feel free to
leave a like' or dislike' as you please
and let me know your thoughts in the
comments below you can watch my previous
video by clicking here or binge watch
them all by clicking here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video